[Music]
imagine a fish swimming in the ocean
on its own the fish is an easy target
for predators and can only find a
limited amount of food but when many
fish form a school
a highly organized structure behaving in
unison
the fish gain power in numbers and
organization
as if behaving as one large organism a
school of fish has an enhanced ability
to swim
find food and evade predators
this ability for a larger structure to
retain and enhance the functions of its
smaller components is also observed in
an exciting field of chemistry
nanocrystals
a crystal is a solid composed of atoms
arranged in a repeating symmetrical
pattern in three-dimensional space
nanocrystals are extremely small
crystals or at least one dimension is
less than a hundred nanometers
the largest nanocrystal is just one one
thousandth of the width of a sheet of
paper
did you know that nanocrystal technology
is already finding its way into our
lives
for example
quantum dots are very small nanocrystals
just 2 to 10 nanometers or 10 to 50
atoms in size along one direction
used in television monitors to produce
displays with higher color accuracy
saturation and brightness than
traditional liquid crystal displays
in the oil industry
zeolite nanocrystals are being used to
refine crude oil into diesel fuel
nanocrystals are also already being used
in drug delivery semiconductor
manufacturing and optics
nanocrystals exhibit special magnetic
electronic and optical properties as a
result of their small size
however like a single fish a single
nanocrystal is often too small to be
useful
one goal of nanocrystal research is to
create nanocrystal superstructures
these are assemblies of nanocrystals in
an ordered three-dimensional
configuration capable of enhancing the
properties of each individual
nanocrystal
there are two broad methods to
synthesize superstructures from
nanocrystals
spontaneous formation and guided
formation
spontaneous formation relies on the
evaporation of a solvent the solution
that the nanocrystals are suspended in
as a solvent evaporates the nanocrystals
are forced closer together until they
form an ordered structure
on the other hand
guided formation depends on the chemical
and physical interactions like hydrogen
bonding and electrostatic attraction to
assemble into an ordered structure based
on nanocrystal to nanocrystal
interactions or nanocrystal the solvent
interactions
superstructures can be
single component made from a single type
of nanocrystal or multi-component made
from two or more types of nanocrystals
scientists believe that nanocrystals and
their superstructures have great
potential to create new materials with
enhanced function
for example a key advantage of
synthesizing multi-component nanocrystal
superstructures is that their functions
can be more easily predicted from the
individual nanocrystals materials used
to create them
this differs from a trial and error
approach of making new materials where
scientists cannot reliably predict the
function of a product from its starting
materials
for example
we would not predict that table salt
which is used to season food
is made of sodium a soft highly reactive
metal
and chlorine a yellow green gas commonly
used as a disinfectant
because table salt does not retain the
properties of either sodium or
chlorine meanwhile in 2014
a group of scientists synthesized a
superstructure that does retain
properties of its starting material
they combined magnetic iron oxide
nanoparticles
iron oxide with cadmium calcagenide
cadmium selenide cadmium sulfide quantum
dot nanocrystals and coated them with a
silica protection layer the scientists
discovered
they were able to magnetically
manipulate the resulting superstructure
in living cells
due to the magnetic properties of iron
oxide and track it using the fluorescent
properties of quantum dots
the silica coating allowed the complex
to safely enter biological systems
with multi-component nanocrystal
superstructures such as this we can
expand the way we observe biological
systems
nanocrystals may be about the nanoscale
but their potential impact on modern
living may be enormous
soon we may see nanocrystal
superstructures designed to combine two
or more catalysts allowing chemical
reactions to become more efficient
smart windows that can let in custom
amounts of visible light and infrared
radiation
wearable sensors and flexible energy
storage devices
gadgets we thought existed only in
science fiction may find themselves
assembling in our reality
[Music]
you